JASON SILVA: So there was
an amazing documentary
called "Flight
From Death," which
distilled the human condition
down to its bare bones,
unbearable awareness
of mortality, like that
is the agitation of mankind.
And the production
company that made the film
is called Transcendental
Media, and they actually
say that their slogan is "to
agitate the sleep of mankind."
Now, what does this hint at?
Well, it hints at
a kind of calling.
it hints at a kind
of responsibility.
To people that
make films, they're
going to encode the
human experience,
to create narratives
that imbibe themselves,
that incept themselves in
our minds to provide context
for who and what we are.
The storytellers
are the ones that
craft the narrative
"that awaken the mind's
attention from the
lethargy custom,"
as Coleridge used to say,
and instead redirect it
towards the wonders of
existence so, again, to agitate
the sleep of mankind.
And today we live in a world
where everybody makes media.
Everybody shares media.
The barriers of entry
have been lowered.
All of us now have a
responsibility then
to output content
that reflects the best
of the human condition.
If media is a drug, are we going
to create narcotic drug that
stupefies its audience with
mindless entertainment,
or are we going to treat
media as a entheogenic that
dissolves boundaries, that
transfigurates modalities
of thought?
Perhaps this is
the kind of media
that we should be celebrating--
media that agitates,
media that transforms,
media that inspires.
Because, again, to agitate
the sleep of mankind
should be all of our goals.
Hey, guys, if you want to
take a look at "Shots of Awe"
behind the scenes, how it
all comes to life, well,
then check out his episode I
shot on "Seeker Stories," which
explores my daily rituals
and how we make "Shots."